a young girl from Maryland who was
reprimanded for kneeling in class during
the national anthem has won the support
of Hillary Clinton the former
presidential candidate tweeted that it
takes courage to express disagreement
with injustice eleven-year-old Marianna
Taylor hopes more people will join her
cause Mariana says that she was inspired
by an American football quarterback who
knelt during the national anthem before
a game in 2016 to protest against racial
inequality and police brutality his
silent protest soon spread among other
athletes and this provoked a fiery
political debate region all the way to
the White House love to see one of these
NFL owners when somebody disrespects our
flag to say get that son of a the field
right now he's fired that was not
against our anthem or our flag that was
actually kneeling as a reverent position
responding to the girls move the
American Civil Rights Union has urged
all Maryland schools to guarantee
students freedom of speech without
punishment meanwhile the girls school
has issued a statement saying it's not
aware of any students being disciplined
for such behavior but Mariana says her
teacher shouted at her and she
reportedly left the classroom in tears
my colleague Andrew farmer discussed the
issue with John Luton a former Missouri
Republican and a Richard Goodstein
former adviser to the Hillary Clinton
presidential campaign footballs about
football schools about school and if you
have a protest protest in a constructive
way
this girl can write letters to the
editor she can arrange a little March
but protesting in your classroom to
irritate your classmate mates and virtue
signal and that's what she's being
taught mom's teaching her mom is so
proud that her daughter is virtue
signaling that she cares more than
anybody else
and I actually find that to make no
sense when you get arrested
disproportionately when you get shot
disproportionately when you get put in
jail
proportionally that's not just annoying
that's totally ruining your life so the
fact that you're taking to the streets
is not merely disruptive you're trying
to make a point unless you have a goal
and something that you actually have a
path to accomplish then you're just
disrupting you're just being an
antagonist
to your fellow athletes or the fans or
in this case to her classmates what does
she want what's gonna make her stand
peace on earth and yeah will we ever get
to the point where there's no
discrimination no there are bigoted
people let's stipulate that there are
people who are bigger than they will be
bigoted forever
Donald Trump has given them voice but
the fact of the matter is it's not to
say it's wrong for them to basically
stand up for what they believe and
that's what this little girl was doing
that's all why on earth are politicians
getting involved in this why can't we
just allow students to protest and
perhaps NFL people to protest if they
want to why is it such a big deal
politically the Democratic Party in the
United States gets their power on
dividing people and separating us versus
them there's class warfare gender
warfare they want to show that
everybody's got a reason for injustice
and they need to vote Democrat or in
order to fix it and that's all this is
it's just it's pure politics rich and
Hillary Hillary Clinton got millions
more votes than Donald Trump did and her
campaign theme was being together not
dividing people she wasn't mocking
handicapped people she wasn't telling
punch him in the jaw and I'll pay your
legal bills that's not what her theme
was her theme was about bringing people
together and she's got millions more
votes than John I'm sorry's the voters
actually disagreed with you
you